[Music]
what up homies I got something special
for my well-read bowlers today I'm about
to lay oh you are the first episode of
my new audio series the notes get lit
well your boy Sparky gonna keep doing
this thing bringing bad as literature to
the streets this town through the
airwaves pod waves whatever the hell is
called this show is live now so check it
out on Apple podcast are your favorite
podcast app but to give you guys a
little taste of what's to come
I'm gonna drop some hitch from the first
episode right here right now three
examples of Mo Money mo problems and
litt have you thought Biggie had at
heart you won't believe this these
characters went through when they
started rolling in the Benjamins number
three
Llewelyn moss from No Country for Old
Men by Cormac McCarthy
it's 1980 and Llewellyn Moss out hunting
in the Texas desert when he stumbles
upon a satchel full of cenotes and a
drug deal that went south dudes an
instant seven-figure baller
unfortunately that money puts him in the
crosshairs of Anton Chigurh a savage
coin flipping hitman hide to retrieve
the stolen loot and this dude don't play
if he say you did you did
I've to sneaking back into the Badlands
to help out a dying man things go from
bad to worse for Louella he's chased
across the desert nearly iced and sent
to the hospital after a shootout with
the seemingly unkillable sugar man I
tell you that dog Anton is like should
night incarnate
I have to hear it your guard threatened
to put one and his wife's dog well and
bust his ass to meet her in El Paso
unfortunately some Mexican hitman smoked
Llywelyn and leave his wife completely
on her own against a girl and that boy
Anton straight-up races her just for
being a farewell and all this damn
that's cold-blooded Llewellyn's life was
straightish the moment he brought on
that saddle
really some say his decision to help
that dying man back in the desert is
what ultimately good amid maybe this is
a sign of who Llewellyn truly is a good
person who's just not cut out for that
thug life or maybe it's a warning that
there ain't no stopping death for anyone
not even for decent folks like Llewellyn
and mrs. Moss
if the cartels didn't careful shigar
sure seemed determined as the double to
dust them both hello I wouldn't skip
town with all the money's I was there no
escaping this showdown with death either
way though I would try to get out of
Dodge with all the muscle his bankroll
could buy him and that kind of cash
can't dunk the Reaper then we're off
number two Jay Gatsby from The Great
Gatsby by F scott Fitzgerald [ __ ] Nick
Carraway lands a job in New York City
during the 20s he rents a Shack next to
the Swank head of Jay Gatsby a
mysterious playboy who throws dope as
parties but never joins them it turns
out Gatsby hosts these rages in the
hopes of attracting his back when honey
dip
Daisy Fame who lives across the bay from
Gatsby's crib with their douchey old
money husband Tom Buchanan after being
blue ball for his Jay and Daisy finally
started hooking up unfortunately they do
his job at keeping it away from Daisy's
hubby who gets his revenge by telling
her how Gatsby made all his bucks
bootlegging yeah that boy gasps be a
hustler man and another twist
Daisy decides to stick it out with her
deadbeat husband girl just can't handle
the thug life that Gatsby side I thought
she was a ride-or-die chick Daisy I'm
disappointed it looks like things
couldn't be worse for Team Gatsby until
Holy Tom's side [ __ ] gets run over by
Daisy and the girl husband thinks Gatsby
was behind the wheel that dead chicks
crazy ass hubby heads down to Gatsby's
mansion and passes him in the swimming
pool it's game over for the Great Gatsby
why did things go south for great Oh
Gatsby
maybe it was because his whole approach
to life will straight up wack brother
thought he can buy his way back to
happiness
with the gangsta wad but Daisy ain't one
of his fancy and shirts that gal is a
human and the human heart ain't the kind
of thing you can buy on Amazon you got a
go on the black market but that kind of
crazy becoming rich didn't make Gatsby
any happier than being rich did for
Daisy I mean just look at her she's a
top-shelf socialite on the surface but
her heart is busted her marriage sucks
and she's shallowest even Nick thought
Gatsby's corny ass view of Daisy being
all perfect wasn't job and what reality
neither character was capable of
achieving the happiness they really
wanted which might be why so many people
compare the great gatsby to the failure
of the American dream
what is the American dream well it
depends on who you ask but it boils down
to bust your ass till you get enough
bread to buy whatever makes you happy
there's the American Dream hold up in
practice well then the Great Gatsby the
verdict is hell no all the American
dream got Jay Gatsby was a death
sentence for vehicular homicide gee
thanks for driving miss daisy'
number one Bilbo Baggins from The Hobbit
by JRR tolkien Bilbo Baggins is a fatass
Hobbit who likes to eat blaze up and do
jack till one day some nappy wizard
crashed his crib with the team of
dwarves and invited him to retake the
Lonely Mountain and all his treasure
from the dragon Smaug
damn that must have been some dank Bilbo
is chief Oh after some major grubbin
fillable joins the gang on a fantastic
journey packed with stranger things than
we've seen on stranger things we're
talking goblins trolls a magic green
that Bilbo pockets and an enormous
dragon chilling top amount of shiny
bling smile gets it correct and the
dwarves reclaim their Mountain the
faster than you can say my precious five
armies hustle over and start scrapping
over to recover the loot this results in
the climactic battle of the five arms
luckily though
Bilbo ducks the drom and survives the
little
shortie pieces out with only a small
percentage prize money but it's all good
he hurries home as fast as his fat Lance
can carry him cuz you know what that
money's going
I've been smoked y'all if you're
wondering why Bilbo didn't help himself
the more of the recovered swag it might
be because so much of the crazy in the
hobbit goes down because of good
old-fashioned greed consider the dwarves
obsession to reclaim the mountain
something Thorin Oakenshield leader of
the dwarves regretted as he lay dying if
more of us valued food and cheering song
above hoarded cold
he says the Bilbo it would be a merrier
world just about everyone in The Hobbit
got their minds on the Dwarven treasure
which might explain why toking chose
Bilbo as his main character as a hobbit
there's a childlike innocence to him
living a simple life
unlike the Dragons dwarves and orcs who
all about the money and the power
this Bilbo's turned off by greed that's
probably tokens cue that we should as
well
that said Bilbo does things up the
middle earth by swiping that one ring
from the creature Gollum was this greed
I wasn't talking setting up his future
books what's the difference because you
know someone was seeing dollar signs
with that moon shoutout to Pete Jackson
three Hobbit movies for please hey
that's all the goods I got today be sure
to be on the lookout for more plug notes
giblet on apple podcast stitcher or
whatever you get you new episodes will
be coming at you every week including
ones on the most infamous banned books
like dropping moments and Shakespeare's
greatest romances and Lynn and more you
can subscribe to the podcast right now
so give it a listen and show you boys
some love and give me a nice review
thanks for tuning in my well-read Ballas
hey
[Music]